i
[Música]
ah
ya antes de que la fan de miel con 19
afectar a las economías de muchos países
en el mundo se calculaba que uno de cada
seis niños en el planeta vivían en
condición de pobreza extrema
esto según el último informe publicado
recientemente por el banco mundial y
unicef esto suma en total 356 de mil
millones de niños en el mundo se calcula
también que dos tercios de esta cifra
viven en áfrica sub-sahariana en hogares
que luchan por sobrevivir con menos de
dos dólares al día por persona también
se calcula que el 20 por ciento de estos
niños tienen menos de 5 años
el informe dice también que entre 2013 y
2017 la cifra de niños que vienen en
condición de pobreza aumentó en 64
millones subiendo la cifra de 234
millones de niños aquí en esta región
del mundo algunos conflictos en áfrica
sub-sahariana que contribuyen a estas
cifras por ejemplo los conflictos en
sudán en república democrática del congo
y en somalia por otra parte el informe
indica también que los sin niños que
viven en áreas rurales tienen el doble
de posibilidad de vivir en condiciones
de pobreza más que los niños que habitan
áreas urbanas
[Música]
ecuador es el segundo país de américa
latina el caribe con los mayores índices
de desnutrición crónica después de
guatemala así lo reveló el propio
gobierno nacional a través de un informe
publicado por las naciones unidas y la
vicepresidencia de la república hay
hambre y desnutrición crónica que
afectan en su mayoría a los niños de 0 a
5 años existen entre el 23 y el 25 por
ciento de niños condenados a mantenerse
en los círculos de pobreza por falta de
desarrollo las cifras se conocieron
luego de publicado un informe del fondo
de las naciones unidas para la infancia
que destaca que de 1 a 6 niños del mundo
vive en la pobreza extrema y podría
aumentar por la pandemia por ello el
poder ha pedido ayudar a naciones unidas
para conocer el impacto del cob y 19 en
su tejido social los resultados fueron
que existe la posibilidad de que ecuador
haya 800 mil nuevos pobres extremos para
año 2021 con riesgo de seguridad
alimentaria según la vicepresidenta de
ecuador que el virus atraso al país 10
años en la reducción de las brechas
sociales con más énfasis en 6 cantones
del país y deberán aplicar estrategias
para reducir estas cifras
[Música]
más de 88 millones de niños en asia
vivían en la pobreza extrema antes de la
llegada de la pandemia según indica el
último informe de unicef y el banco
mundial de ellos 11,9 millones viven en
china especialmente en las zonas rurales
de la franja más occidental del país en
provincias como ganso como tíbet o
xinjiang donde el partido comunista
chino ha endurecido además la represión
contra la minoría uigur pero ante todo
la pobreza infantil en asse se concentra
en el sur del continente eminentemente
en india donde 53 3 millones de niños
residen en hogares que sobreviven con
menos de dos dólares al día de hecho el
informe indica que el 11 7 por ciento de
los niños nacidos en india el segundo
país más poblado del mundo lo hacían ya
en la pobreza extrema antes de la
aparición de lakovic 19 la cual promete
empeorar aún más esta situación si los
gobiernos advierte el estudio no
empiezan a invertir ya en programas de
recuperación infantil
[Música]